if this amazing actor isn't being
considered for doctor who
then he should be
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
we obviously know that jodie whittaker
is about to leave her role as the doctor
in doctor who and
there are loads of rumors about who
might replace her and as many women as
men um michael sheen ifan reese
just the names go on and on but there's
one actor that i really think has been
overlooked and he could actually do the
role because he's not signed up to any
major thing at the moment he's not 720
major tv series or many major movies so
he honestly could become the next doctor
who
well if you're a sci-fi fan you know
this guy's face and
most sci-fi fans absolutely adore him of
course i mean mark shepard
now for me
mark shepard i got to fall in love with
him basically um for his part in
leverage not a sci-fi show obviously but
his character sterling really was one of
the highlights of what was actually i
thought a really really good show
most people particularly sci-fi fans
know him from supernatural
hey
hey
cut it out man
image
you're the king of rotten act like it
his character of crowley
and personally one of my favorites
badger from firefly
yeah look at me
what's your story love
she's
just uh just a passenger yeah
why'd she talk
she's got a secret
why do i think he should be the doctor
well in a recent interview with michael
rosenbaum on inside of you he talked
really fondly about his time on doctor
who didn't you do doctor who too
how many episodes i did uh two
episodes at the beginning of season six
do you still get people coming up to you
for doctor girls
it's wonderful he already actually
played a part in the episode the
impossible astronaut he played an
american retired fbi agent with a really
ridiculously long name let me have a
second here
canton everett de la ware the third
so does that mean he can't actually be
the doctor now because he's already
appeared in the series well we know from
star trek that actors come back and play
lots and lots of different roles it
doesn't really matter people have a
pretty short memory and actually the
doctor can look like whatever he wants
to so maybe you know that's the reason
why but to be honest if they just cast
this guy as the role and some people
might go this is where he's already been
in it but nobody will really care but i
do actually have a couple of reasons why
i think he could be perfect for the role
one he is a proper serious actor but
he's also we know from his role as
badger got a real cheeky side he's got a
really cool voice and he can play very
ominous very imposing characters i mean
what happens
to you
if we go up against the devil
and lose number one he's gonna wipe us
all out anyway two after you leave here
i go on an extended vacation to all
points nowhere and three how about you
don't miss okay
morons
we can also play silly fun characters
and we know that the doctor has elements
of both
he can be cheeky funny even silly but
can also be very ominous very
threatening
i want to see this twist between the two
i would also say that actually mark
shepard is an actor that is probably
better known in the united states than
he is known over here
and for the bbc that would be a
no-brainer really because however
popular doctor who is in the uk
if it really wants to be successful
get it popular in america and at times
doctor who has been incredibly popular
in the united states so maybe casting
this actor could give it a little bit of
a resurgence a little bit of a bump um
for our cousins over the ocean tino i've
never seen doctor who it's fantastic
i'll tell you where to start to what i
mean which doctor do i start with no
well
the thing is what you grew up with is
your doctor right but me personally it's
not a bad place to start is it not to go
into monster of the week stuff but but
there is a really interesting arc that
starts with fish fingers and custard you
can do this for him
when matt smith starts at fish fingers
and custard goes through pandorica
through christmas
into the stuff i did in season six which
is written by neil gaiman so is this a
serious idea for doctor who well
honestly i'm absolutely certain they've
already picked the doctor they're being
very very careful not to announce it and
it's been very very secretive they've
done that with almost every doctor
written up until now but doctor who does
need a real serious boost in popularity
it is at an all-time low and even though
the popularity of doctor who's always
put in ebbs and waves if the next doctor
fails like unfortunately jodie whittaker
did even though i thought she was
absolutely brilliant as the doctor
if it fails again i honestly think this
will be the last doctor we see for a
while i could very honestly say that
doctor who will probably be cancelled if
it fails again and the popularity
continues to wane and we'll probably
have a gap of well let's hope it's not
like a decade like it was last time but
i could see us having no doctor on our
screens for a few years at least i think
the character is too popular and it's
too big a franchise for us to never see
it again
but i honestly think this doctor who
needs to succeed we've kind of had two
fails now since matt smith left they
really really need this to work and i
honestly think mark shepard would be the
perfect choice but before you get too
excited i do not have any sources when
it comes to the bbc this is only my
opinion but with every other name that's
been thrown into the hat for rumors that
could play the doctor this is one that
really should be in the mix and if the
bbc haven't at least considered him
there it is so get in the comments tell
me who would you like to see as the next
doctor would you like to see a man or
another woman or whatever else what do
you think about some of the roles like
hugh grant that's been
room if this keeps going around what do
you think about that and reese vance is
actually a really interesting idea for
me
get in the comments tell me what you
think and if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit the bell
notification it really helps us out and
you can consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker consider hitting
the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you